it's 43 days and counting and joe biden
still
hasn't held a solo news conference and
talk about terrible optics
take a look at what happened when biden
was ready to take questions from
democrats
during an event yesterday
thank you thank you and i'm happy to
take questions if that's
what i'm supposed to do nance whatever
you want me to do
happy to take questions yeah and i'm
happy to get a colonoscopy without
anesthesia
um apparently the q a was never intended
to be public
but it still looks pretty bad for joe
dana from public relations standpoint
uh you were served in the bush white
house uh is this an
absolute disaster ranking from one
an absolute disaster to ten an
absolute terrible good disaster
greg it's worse than watergate yes
um i i could imagine this happening like
you're not supposed to do q a he's it's
like a natural ending to the event and
he's all
you joe biden remember he was not shy
about talking to reporters for
most of his career he was like
accessible he talked to anybody which
was one of the reasons that people liked
it liked him
um i think that he's going to need a
news event
in order to then do a big press
conference and i've said that i think
that they will wait till they get this
coveted relief
through the senate and i would imagine
that by the time he does a signing
ceremony then you'll see him take a lot
of questions
but i also have to say this if george w
bush
had ended an event where we weren't
intending to take questions but he had
said
happy to take your questions you think
i'm going to jump on that grenade and
say like no no he can't take questions
like he's the president of the united
states if he wants to take questions
let him take questions yeah you know
juan it makes it look like
nancy pelosi is actually running the
country and not joe
yeah well
clearly she got joda's attention she had
him there you know for her event with
the democrats
you know i one thing i would just say
here you know joe biden loves people
and loves to chit chat it is one of his
strengths and
certainly access to reporters yesterday
morning by the way we're talking about
this
the white house reporters who cover him
got to ask questions so
you know this is a time of pandemic i
think he's the first president a hundred
years take office during a pandemic that
affects things
but also and i think this is important
when we think about what happened
yesterday with that democratic session
he's at the three-yard line in terms of
passing
a major coveted relief bill and i think
that his aides don't want any fumble at
the three-yard line they don't want to
stir up any huge controversy
that's aimed at keeping keeping a lid on
disagreements private
among democrats not at terms of general
access uh to reporters you know uh judge
that bill obviously would have been
passed a couple
you know maybe four or five months ago
but we had a different president what
about the fact that like
compared to trump i mean trump would
talk to anybody if a
rabbit skittered across the lawn he'd go
what do you want
yeah yeah here's the thing i mean trump
was
open he was transparent what you know
what he said what he said he was going
to do and did what he
said he was going to do i mean and just
to follow up on your question greg i
mean
like who's running the country i think
everybody wants to know who's running
the country
and an answer to juan uh if he's on the
three-yard line
and they don't they don't want him to
fumble i mean guys the president of the
united states
should you're worried about him fumbling
he's like the leader of the free world
get him out there
let him do his thing and run it in he
wants to
yeah bring it home that's a good point
uh jesse
uh could could it be that can i just
pick up on something
sure let me just react to the judge
because that was right
i mean joe biden won what more votes
than any other
politician in u.s history the guy's a
huge
star allegedly he's the tom brady of
politics
broke all voting records and you think
he's going to screw it up by answering a
question
from a dopey reporter juan you don't
have very much trust in this guy do you
listen the hyden biden act worked during
the campaign
right that it was able to make it a a
referendum on donald trump because they
let the tech giants
and the media do joe's dirty work but
he's a solo act now on
you got to give the guy the ball and let
him air it out this
is like this is the big leagues now you
know
he could go out there he could do okay
but that's fine
he doesn't have to hit a home run we
just want to know what he thinks
but i don't know if he knows what he
thinks guy's a weathervane
he does whatever the left wants so that
he was tough on crime
now he's soft on crime he was for iraq
now against iraq
you don't know what he thinks and that's
all we want to know what do you think
joe what do you think
four sports analogies jesse four
sorry golf there was football there was
baseball and there was some other sport
that
i think i think he worked in a soccer
reference in there
did i have a shot on goal there yes i
would never i don't like soccer
i don't want him to make an own goal
there you go